next story bone appeti writes I am
begging restaurants to stop explaining
that everything is sharable you all know
that experience when you go to like a
topus restaurant or a restaurant where
they it's all family style and the
server comes out explains now welcome
this is this is a sharable restaurants
you're going to want to order they're
saying that's annoying they don't want
to they understand where they are I say
I love it keep talking keep talking
about the food you're going to bring me
keep talking about how delicious it is
love a sharable plate because I don't
love I love ordering like Littles
because if I order an entree I'm like
kind of stuck with that and I'll be
honest with you if we order something at
the same dinner table I'm eating half of
what you ordered 100% right are you like
that too I love it I love it thank God I
always over order every time I take my
friends out the plates come and then
they keep coming and then they keep
coming it's like well wait a minute this
isn't just for you to eat or for me to
eat it's for us to eat right sharing is
caring I sometimes like it when they
talk to me you know when they're like
giving me the the whole breakdown it's
like a little bit of culinary foreplay
you know I'm like okay here we're
getting into the meal oh you have me
with culinary foreplay for sure okay
well last up real simple reveals this
unexpected Tik Tock hack turns your
handheld mixer into a stand mixer this
viral video shows a standard metal
mixing bowl and a handheld mixer a wire
rack comes together and guess what voila
you have a hand mixer and hand mixers
actually cost way less now this is a
hand mixer n that I made it's by our
company um beautiful they are
beautiful the reason that I love this is
because it stores so well you know right
in here if I may are these things which
usually you little guys go missing so I
put them right in there I put them right
here and it looks more attractive and
then you can fold the cord up in it as
well so we're going to demonstrate the
beautiful hand mixers gentlemen if you
will show us what the latest in Tik Tok
is all about how do we do it I have no
idea what I'm doing so you see they put
these through the little r understand
okay so now we just set it down and turn
it on here I'll even hold your un set
and forget look at that oh wait a minute
pause can we I bet we can even move it
can't we yeah kind of like a sewing
machine yeah see and you have to have a
partner with you thank you drew let's go
I love it well speaking of Tik Tok and I
am a stcker for Tik Tok we have a new
segment breaking right here today on the
show called scene on Tik Tok and I am so
here for
[Music]
it